rainbow 6 siege has been delayed
December first 315 is the new release
date the same day as Just Cause 3
curiously enough to and I've got Mike
McCarty an errant Sampson here to chat a
little bit about the disappointment of
Rainbow six siege being bumped a couple
months also bad betas in general and
they got a lot of thoughts about
yourself iron first of all Mike add
details on this bad boy it's been pushed
three months surprised at all uh a
little bit i mean the imeem the bay the
good thing is the beta is still what
September to mid-september yeah yeah the
bait is still the same date so you're
still gonna be able to get your hands on
the closed beta they've been throwing
keys away like nobody's business like
you're you're gonna be able to play in
this game it does haven't been delayed
that much yeah I suppose come out in
October it's been pushed back to
December it's not so bad and it did she
talk about the beta because this is a
game that like has been really been
baited for like a year now like it and
there's been a couple of them and I
remember keep going back and new stuff
being out and being tweaked a lot yeah I
mean games go into betas for I mean when
they go into beta is for the right
reason it's for balance that's what they
always claim when they delay is will we
get we need time to like actually dig
through our plate s and fix the games
there's a couple of games it's
interesting like a good case study was
battlefield hardline yes did too many
betas yeah right after e3 when they
nested like I think that weekend yeah I
had the first beta and then they
fundamentally scrapped out almost an
entire mode they just kind of rejigged
everything from there you think it had
too many tho thread it's like yeah like
betas are kind of an art form if you
give away too much of your game then
when it launches people might have
already played your game you know I mean
some games like even destiny when it
originally launched I think you'd played
about a fifth of the content yeah Roy
yeah by the time it launched because of
the beta was on one of those I don't
like four or five planets also you can
argue with all the changes they've made
that this past year has been a beta yeah
sounds interesting betas are something
that developers can use if they use them
right and they use their delays right
you end up with a better game if they
use them wrong you've already burned out
your audience before you launch your
title I'm also curious because didn't
they kind of say that the reason
beta was to largely work on the coop
like the ex Pacific co-op mode were
already the terrorist hunt yeah
terrorist hunt was a highly requested
mode by the fans I I think a lot of
people who you know played Vegas and
some of the other titles they like
multiplayer not everybody loves
multiplayer just because you know it's
one life you get hit and you're out you
got to sit there and watch it watch your
friends finish every match so having
that co-op is important because it lets
you stay alive longer do more with your
friends we played it at e3 and it was
actually very challenging which I
thought was cool like we played on the
higher level mode are the higher
difficulty modes and the AI was quite
good and your team communication had to
be good so a lot of the strategies were
the same so it's a more excessive
terrorist tongue as like a more
accessible version of the multiplayer
which I'm curious why that's our like
having so many field played siege
already i'm wondering why I pushed it
back again I wonder what actually was
the impetus for that final decision was
there because I've played a little bit
of us Erin I know you've said a lot more
are there any standard sort of parts of
Rainbow six siege that you think
required dressing was there like a lack
of modes like of maps or was there was
there like gameplay stuff that you think
actually didn't need a lot of TLC one of
the things that they could get a little
handicapped on is the fact they only
showed 10 of their 20 classes right so
you know the maybe people got really
good with the first ten one of them you
know including pulse who could see
through walls he was a little
overpowered so they tweaked his ability
but then you know you're gonna launch
the game there's gonna be another ten
player and any of them could break the
game I mean you know they showed a medic
class recently who can fire revival
darts hmm there's any number of things
that a new class member can do to mess
with the game so do you think like
developers are baby gunning a little bit
gun-shy in terms of releasing games that
are like imbalance like I was talking to
the overwatch guys at Gamescom and
they've basically used every event via
blizzcon or packs even III and games
calm as well as like ways of basically
like doing a be testing and like you
know alpha testing or beta testing their
game there
do you think like people are a little
bit reticent of releasing game that is
like perfectly polished me balancing
yeah especially in light of the last
couple of years especially with so many
games you could name like a name like
three off the top my head I had pretty
poor release states you know like
there's battlefield hardline Mike you
mentioned then there's Assassin's Creed
unity which isn't as multiplayer focused
but it's kind of if they're up front
about it and say this is gonna be our
beta this is our release I'm I'm fine
with what Ubisoft's doing with a siege
just because I mean again if it's it's
not that much of a delay but it's still
a delay but if it's not gonna be like
another four months like at least is
this calendar year yeah Yves give them
on came out i think it was around III
saying like this was going to be the
biggest FPS ubisoft ever made yeah they
wanted to add cell far cry 4 they're
obviously like wanting this to be like a
big eSport do you like a gia like a
chemist right go level kind of of people
playing it you always have to be a
little careful though as a journalist
when it comes to those sorts of
ambitious statements that's the kind of
thing that your audience will tell you
if you have if you're telling your
audience that's when it's going to be
that may or may not happen does it feel
like that to you you're somebody play's
massive amounts of like online
first-person shooters it's specifically
like military tactical ones does it CH
feel like that type of breakthrough game
Rainbow six siege I I personally love
the tactical combat I like the change of
pace but it's gonna have to prove that
it's not like evolved which was really
good at doing one thing but ended up a
lot of people felt just being a
one-trick pony and if you didn't like
that pony like then the game had nothing
for you right it turns out after it
seemed like anyway in the months after
involves release that not enough people
did like that pony in the fall off was
like that hurts the game so much more
when there's not a lot of people playing
out like you need that critical mass
right so yes you just gonna have to
prove that it's a more versatile game if
they want it to be competitive with far
cry I mean you know you're not going to
be popping a wingsuit and like flying
200 feet down a canyon and then stabbing
an elephant to death with it you know
shovel unless that ever gonna happen and
what they delayed it for yeah i guess
i'll have to wait and find out Iron Mike
thank you so much come on talking all
about rainbow 6 siege which would be out
like I said first day of December right
before Christmas and that is if you're
not playing just cause 3 that day
we're going to be back in a second
talking about call of duty black ops 3
having tweeted it was black ops 2
earlier accidentally there's so many
call of duty games to have Vlad to point
to point 5 well the beta right now
notice that because all the beta to my
mind